-Welcome back to the program.
Thanks for being here.
-Welcome back to you. How glad
are we that Jimmy is back?
-I am so happy.
-And the Roots are back!
I missed it so much.
-This building's not the same
without you. It's lonely.
-Is it?
-I come in here at 4:00 a.m.
I come up here. I sleep
in your office, obviously.
I play Quest's drums.
-Yeah. We weren't allowed
in the building.
I haven't been here
in five months.
-I know.
We're so glad you're back, man.
-I'm so happy to be back.
Thank you, buddy.
I'm so thankful. I missed this.
This is so good for my ego.
Yeah, I really needed this.
How's the fam?
How are the kids?
How's everybody?
-Good. Good.
I've got two teenagers now.
It's coming for you, too.
Not yet, but it's coming.
I've got a 16-year-old
and a 14-year-old.
-I think you'd be good at this.
-We got great kids.
That's where you start.
But also you start --
You start to feel your age.
I'm pushing 50.
I don't know about you.
-Me too. Me too.
-I'm on the cusp of it.
-And we took our kids to
Gov Ball a couple of months ago,
which is this big music festival
in New York
where all, like, the hottest,
coolest bands play.
-Oh, yeah.
-And we took 20
16-year-olds to see Gov Ball
and we put them on a bus, and
we were in an escort vehicle.
We were not allowed on the bus.
And we went with them to Queens
to this music concert,
and we thought
we were pretty cool.
-That's cool parents.
-But we went to the --
There's a tent they set up
for chaperones, basically.
So we're lying in the tent.
They have beds put out because
they know who you are,
and you kind of lie there
and play Wordle
and you listen to some bands...
while my daughter
and her friends are over
listening to Lil Uzi Vert
and Metro Boomin
and Ice Spice and Joey Badass
and all these bands
that they love.
-And you're playing Wordle
in a tent.
-We're playing Wordle in a tent.
-Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
-And so at one point,
we go over and we say,
"Let's be cool and hang out
with the kids," right?
And so we're listening.
And Joey Badass
says something like,
"Hey, to all the ladies..."
You know, it's really, like,
flattering to women.
And my wife goes, "You know
what? Thank you, Johnny Badass."
[ Laughter ]
-Close. Close.
-And I said, "It's Joey.
Let's get you back in the tent."
-[ Laughs ] Johnny Badass.
-Let's get you back in the tent.
We'll have a mojito in the tent.
-Yeah, we'll play
some more Wordle. Yeah.
You know any five-letter words?
-Yeah.
-I was gonna ask you
about some news headlines
and see what your take is
on everything.
Nothing too crazy, but how about
what everyone's talking about?
Travis and Tay-Tay.
-You joke, but it is what
everyone's talking about.
I cover the news every day
and what's going on
with Donald Trump
and Kevin McCarthy and Congress
and all that.
And yet when on my phone
it pops up, I'm like,
"Babe! Travis Kelce's
jersey sales are up 400%!"
[ Laughter ]
-It is every other headline.
-She's like,
"That's not something."
But I don't know
exactly what's going on.
I do have a little bit
of a theory.
I hope it's not controversial.
I'm happy for both of them.
They seem like great people.
-Yeah.
-Is there any chance
that this is all
one big Capital One commercial?
In other words, are we gonna
go through weeks of this
and at the end they turn
to the camera and say,
"What's in your wallet?"
-Yeah, okay.
No, no, I don't think --
I think this is real.
-Do you think it's real?
-I think it's as real as can be.
-I hope it is. I think it is.
-And I think
they're both cool people.
-Very cool.
-I think -- I would love --
It's almost like
when you see two people
that you go like,
"They should date."
Like,
"I want to be at that party.
I want to be at this party."
-Yeah. No. I'm totally on board.
I just want to put it
in the universe,
if it happens, that I was right.
-It's a Capital One ad.
-Yeah.
-Let's talk about Trump.
This is day three of
the Trump civil fraud trial.
I was gonna ask you, were you
surprised that he showed up?
Because he didn't
have to show up, right?
-You're right.
It's a civil trial.
He doesn't have to be there
as a defendant.
-Why is he there?
-So he shows up, in part,
I think,
to sit in that courtroom,
get the photograph
kind of glaring at the witnesses
and the judge and
and the district attorney
and everybody,
at the attorney general.
And then really
what he's there for
is the moment
where he walks out --
And he did it again today.
He walks out of those doors
and he makes a speech
and he says this is a disgrace
and it's a witch hunt
and all of the other things.
So like a lot of things
in his life, it's performative,
and he wants
to reinforce the idea
that this is
somehow a witch hunt.
But it does get to everything
he has built,
which is, "I'm a businessman.
I'm a successful guy.
I'm 'The Apprentice.'
And this is why I was elected.
This is why you know me."
And this civil trial
really gets at that,
which says --I don't know.
There was perhaps some fraud
involved in that whole image.
-Wow. Interesting.
That's an interesting take.
So. Yeah. Okay. Alright.
I see. I like that.
-It's also a Capital One
commercial.
-You think he's doing a Capital
One commercial, as well?
-I do.
-How about this?
Yesterday,
the House voted to remove
Kevin McCarthy
as Speaker of the House.
What happens now? Who takes
over? And what does it all mean?
-It's absolutely wild.
Kevin McCarthy desperately
wanted this job
for his entire career.
He had it for 269 days --
about 9 months.
But to get the job,
he agreed to a rule
that said one member of Congress
can raise a motion
to get rid of him.
And so the minute they didn't
like something he did,
they did it,
they took him up on it.
So it was a job he wanted
that he held for nine months.
And it's not clear to me
who gets the job after --
There are names out there --
Steve Scalise and Jim Jordan
and some other people.
But it's --
-Trump's name came up.
Yeah. Some people said,
"What if we just made Donald
Trump the Speaker of the House?"
-Speaker of the House?
-That's not gonna happen.
Don't worry.
That's not going to happen.
-I'm not gonna happen.
-No.
-And like everything else, this
is a Capital One commercial.
What's happening now.
Is that too much?
-No, no. It's perfect.
I want to say,
I think you're coming up on
or just did your 300th episode
of "Sunday Today."
-Yeah, we just had our --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-I was one of the first.
-You were early.
-I was in there early, right?
I was one of the first on
"Sunday Today
with Willie Geist."
-Jimmy was there very early
with, I think,
your first children's book.
-Yeah.
-Jimmy Fallon
was a guest on our show.
-I loved doing you show.
-And also your ice cream.
Yeah, it was your
Ben & Jerry's ice cream.
-That's right. We had fun.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I know everyone asks
who your favorite guest is,
and you don't have to say.
We all know, but...
[ Laughter ]
But who is your favorite type
of guest?
Is it a politician?
Is it a comedian?
-I love -- Yes.
Comedians are great.
I love a musician.
I love a musician. I do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Unbelievable.
-What I love is hearing
how songs are built.
I interviewed Jack Antonoff
yesterday.
Actually, I saw Quest there
after I did that yesterday.
I interviewed Jack Antonoff
talking about --
"So you and Taylor Swift
get in a room. Now what?
Like, how do you make
'1989' and 'Reputation'
and 'Midnights'
and all that stuff?"
-Well, you're back with
a new episode of "Sunday Today"
this weekend.
Who do you have on this Sunday?
-We got Darius Rucker.
The great Darius Rucker.
-Ooh. He's got a new record
coming out.
-He's got a new album
As, you know,
one of the all-time great guys.
-He really is, man. He's solid.
-And what a ride, right?
Like, the Hootie & the Blowfish
album
was the eighth-biggest-selling
in the history of bands,
in the history of music --
like, with the Eagles
and the Beatles
and the Stones and Led Zeppelin
and all that.
-They were a bar band, right?
North Carolina?
-Exactly.
College band in South Carolina.
-South Carolina.
-Yeah.
And now he's become
this country star.
So, Darius will be on
this weekend. Yeah.
-Willie, I love you.
I love everything you do.
I love "Sunday Today."
I love "Morning Joe."
I love you on the "Today" show,
and I love you
on "The Tonight Show."
-Thanks, man.
I'm so glad you're here.
-You're the best.
-Welcome back, guys.
-Willie Geist. Check him out
on "Sunday Today"
and weekday mornings
on "Morning Joe."